Well Colton, Kevin,
congratulations, guys.
The two of you are going forward
in the third and final round
of the young guns competition.
Now bladesmiths, we want to send
you back to your home forges
for four days to build this.
NARRATOR: The German long sword.
The German long sword
traces its roots
back to 14th century Europe.
This two handed weapon
was powerful enough
to deliver deadly blows
and its double edged blade
inflict deep wounds and
slashes against any enemy
that came across its path.
The massive blade was so
powerful that skilled warriors
had to train extensively
in the art of long sword
fencing to master its strength.
While this weapon was no
longer used in combat,
long sword fencing is practiced
around the world today.
Both of you should be
on your A-game and bring
back your very best work.
Because at the end of
the day, only one of you
is going to be leaving here
with his second "Forged
in Fire champion" title
and a check for $10,000.
Bladesmiths, good luck.
We will see you in four days.
My name is Kevin Burgess.
I am 22.
I'm from Nacogdoches, Texas.
I am currently a
full-time college student
and a part-time bladesmith Last
time I was here it was a blast
but I was about as entertaining
as watching paint dry.
I decided that if I was
going to come back on here,
I was going to try and
show people that I do
have somewhat of a personality.
Ah, that's a really long blade.
If I mess up on a measurement
then it's all over.
So it's just kind of check it
constantly, see where I am,
see whether or not
I've hit parameters
and just keep on
going from there.
It's about to go
into heat treat.
Just straight up,
straight into the oil.
I'm noticing that
towards the tip it just
barely kicks off to the side.
At this point, that
blade is a spring
and it just keeps on
going back to exactly
where it was and I can't seem
to get it to go back straight.
I couldn't get it out and
I just got to live with it.
But it does hurt my
chances at winning.
I'm going to add
little cubic zirconium
diamonds to the handle.
Cool.
I'm pretty worried about
the warp will send me home
but I'm hoping that my attention
to detail on the handle
might be able to
carry me to a win.
My name's is Colton Arias.
I'm 20 years old and
I'm from Nebraska.
When I first won "Forged in
Fire," I was 18 years old.
I was barely legal.
But now I'm back.
I'm 20 years old and
about 20 pounds heavier.
So I've grown physically
into a larger human
and I've also grown my
skills in bladesmithing.
From experience, I know
the greatest challenge
with any long sword build,
especially if I'm doing it out
of Damascus, is going to
be keeping it straight
and making sure the
temper and the heat treat
are spot on so it
does not break.
Plenty of things can go wrong
when you're clenching a sword.
It could crack.
It could warp.
It could fracture.
Let's hope none of that
happens because everything
is riding on this quench.
Awesome.
Perfect.
This thing is massive.
In a build like this, a
million things can go wrong.
If you make one false step
or try to rush it too much
you could ruin the whole
thing in the last step
or in the first step.
I'm completely done
with the sword.
Fit and finish.
It's damn near perfect.
That's a legendary sword.
Young "Forged in
Fire" champions,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your German long swords will do,
I'm going to take your weapon
and deliver some lethal
blows on this pig carcass.
Colton, you're first.
Ready for this?
Do it.
[music playing]
All right, Colton, let's talk
about your German long sword.
Every slice was a
very deep slice.
Overall, the balance, the feel
of your sword it will KEAL.
Kevin.
Your turn.
You ready?
You know it.
[music playing]
All right, Kevin,
those are very deep cuts,
almost cut through the
pig on the first strike.
Now earlier, prior to this, you
had a little bend at the tip
but it didn't get any worse.
Overall, your weapon,
sir, it will KEAL.
Thank you very much.
Doug almost went through
my pig on the first slice.
I was really kind of
[clicks tongue] yeah.
But it was not quite
enough to distract him
from the warp in the sword so
he did end up noticing that
and that could be
what sends me home.
Bladesmiths, welcome to the
strength test, the throne chop.
In order to test the
strength of your edge
as well as the
overall construction
of your German long
swords, I'll be
bashing them into this throne.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
All right.
[music playing]
All right, Colton this is
a great looking blade, man.
I like your Damascus pattern.
It's still nice and
straight, didn't
take much damage beyond a
slight glinting so well done.
Thank you.
All right, Kevin,
you're up, man.
You ready?
- You know it.
All right.
[music playing]
All right, Kevin, well your
sword, it's all in one piece.
Again, the slightest of glinting
on the edge from contact
with the wood, but nothing
I would call damage.
You had a slight
warp to it coming in.
That hasn't changed.
It's the same.
All in all, you
know, I think you
did a good job on your grinds.
The weight is good and it held
up great in strength test.
Nice job.
Thank you very much.
All right, young guns,
this is a sharpness
test, the cowhide bag slice.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Colton,
your edge cuts cleanly.
It's razor sharp.
In thrusting, drawing
it back, and cutting,
the balance is good.
And overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
Kevin, your turn.
You ready?
You know it.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Kevin,
your edge, razor sharp.
It cut cleanly all
through the bags.
And overall, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, throughout
this competition,
you both have amazed
us tremendously.
But as you know, only one of
you can go home with the win.
The judges have talked it over
and they made a final decision.
The bladesmith going
home with a check
for $10,000 and his second
"Forged in Fire" champion title
is--
Colton.
Congratulations.
Kevin, you fought hard and you
brought us a beautiful blade
but unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Peace.
It turns out that I am not going
to be the two-time youngest
champion but losing to
Colton, he's an amazing smith,
does amazing work and
I'm glad it was him
and not somebody else.
Well, Colton, that means
you are the youngest two-time
"Forged in Fire" champion
and you got yourself
another check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Being the youngest
two-time "Forged in Fire"
champion feels amazing.
I mean, this is probably one
of the closest competitions
that I have seen and to come
out on top, it just feels great.
Really, really well done.
My name is Colton Arias
and I'm the youngest two-time
"Forged in Fire" champion.